Okay, Michael what's the answer?
>> Well, it's still a half. But I guess we, we really should
take into consideration those probability. So
the number of mismatches they have, but
the actual number of errors, the expected number of errors is like well,
a 20th plus 20th, so like a 10th. So it's 90% correct, 10% error.
>> Right. That's exactly right, so, what's important to see here
is that even though you may get many examples wrong, in some
sense some examples are more important than others. Because
some are very rare. And if you think of error,
or the sort of mistakes that you're making, not as
the number of distinct mistakes you can make, but rather
the amount of time you will be wrong, or the
amount of time you'll make a mistake, then you can
begin to see that it's important to think about the
underlying distribution of examples that. You see. You buy that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, so, that notion of error
turns out to be very important for boositng because in the
end, boosting is going to use this trick of distributions in order
to define what hardest is. Since we are going to have learning
algorithms that do a pretty god job of learning on a bunch
of examples. We're going to pass along to them a distribution
over the examples, which is another way of saying, which examples are
important to learn, versus which examples are not as important to
learn. And that's where the hardest notion is going to come in.
So, every time we see a bunch of examples, we're
going to try to make the harder ones more important to get
right. Than the ones that we already know how to solve.
And I'll, I'll describe in a minute exactly how that's done.
>> But isn't it the case that this distribution
doesn't really matter? You should just get them all right.
>> Sure. But now it's a question of
how you're going to get them all right. Which
brings me to my second definition I want to
make. And that second definition is a weak learner.
So there's this idea of a learning algorithm, which is
what we mean by a learner here. As being weak. And
that definition's actually fairly straightforward
so straightforward in fact that you
can sort of forget that it's really important. And all a
weak learners is, is a learner that no matter what
the distribution is over your data, will do better than chance
when it tries to learn labels on that data. So what
does does better than chance actually mean? Well what it means
is, that no matter what the distribution over the
data is, you're always going to have an error rate that's
less than a half. So that means sort of
as a formalism, is written down here below. That for
all D, that is to say no matter what
the distribution is, your learning algorithm We'll have an expected
error. That is the probability that it will disagree with
it through actual concept if you draw a single sample
that is less than or equal to one half
minus Epsilon. Now epsilon is a term that you end
up seeing a lot in mathematical proofs and particularly ones
involving machine learning. And epsilon just means a really, really
small number somewhere between a little bigger than 0 and
certainly much smaller than 1. So, here what this means
technically is that you're bounded away from 1 1/2. Which
another way of thinking about that is you always get
some information from the learner. The
learner's always able to learn something. Chance
would be the case where your probability is 1/2 and you actually learn
nothing at all which kind of ties us back into the notion of information
gained way back when with decision trees. So does that all make sense Michael?
>> I'm not sure that I get this right. Let's, maybe we can do
a quiz and just kind of nail down some of the questions that I've got.
>> Okay, sure. You got an idea for a quiz?
>> Sure.